wir werden diese woche entscheiden ob
wir den hof kaufen oder nicht ich habe
euch ja schon erzählt dass wir ausziehen
müssen und dass wir einen ganz ganz ganz
schönen tollen hof in aussicht haben auf
dem ich all meine selbstversorger träume
verwirklichen könnte aber da gibt es
einige schwierigkeiten da gibt es noch
einige große fragezeichen die wir gerade
nach und nach klären
und am ende dieser woche wird die
entscheidung anstehen und da möchte ich
euch diese woche einfach mal mitnehmen
euch zeigen was uns so bewegt was wir
überlegen wenn wir jetzt einen hoch
suchen das hilft vielleicht auch
denjenigen von euch weiter die gerade
auch auf haus oder hof suche sind ganz
viele von euch haben mir geschrieben als
er gerade in einer ähnlichen situation
seit wir nicht richtig auf jeden fall
ganz fest die daumen wenn ihr auch
gerade am suchen seit ich weiß dass das
viel viele kräfte zehrt und super
anstrengend es ist es so
nervenaufreibend und aufregend und
stetiges auf und eigentlich weil wir so
große träume haben und ich da so viel
rein projiziere schon auf diesem hof und
gleichzeitig gibt es so große probleme
die damit einhergehen dass ich
eigentlich ganz vernünftig bin sagen
würde diesen hof werden wir
realistischerweise nicht nehmen aber
vielleicht sind wir auch gar nicht so
realistisch und diese woche wird die
entscheidung fallen das heißt vielleicht
haben wir bald einen hof mit 25 hektar
acht kühen den schafen 30 hühnern und
ewig hier platz alles zu verwirklichen
was wir so in unserem trage oder man
zwar nicht so in mir trage aber
vielleicht ist es auch einfach die
weißeste entscheidung zu sagen dass
dieses haus und dieser hof einfach
realistischerweise nicht so wirklich zu
uns passen denn da gibt es einige große
probleme die wir nicht
ignorieren sollten ich bin auf jeden
fall selber total gespannt wie der
ausgang dieses videos sein wird es ist
schon spät am abend im karton gut im
rufen aber dann geht es ab ins bett und
wir sehen uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
ich hatte ja im letzten video erzählt
dass es für uns gerade zwei optionen
gibt einmal diesen hof zu kaufen der
schon ziemlich viel von dem was ich mir
wünsche mit sich bringt es gibt ein
erzieher oder ein komplett neues haus zu
bauen wir haben auch andere hilfe
angeschaut und andere häuser angeschaut
da war aber bisher nichts dabei was
irgendwie zu uns gepasst hätte und bei
dem bauland da haben wir jetzt schon mit
den besitzern geredet also es gab drei
baugrundstücke hier bei uns in der nähe
die in frage kommen würden weil da noch
so viel land hinten raus mit dran wäre
oder noch so viel zu kostbar wäre das
weder auch unsere tiere halten könnten
und vielleicht auch noch geld erhalten
könnten und einen großen garten anlegen
könnten und so weiter machst du eben
alles bevor aber leider wollen alle drei
besitzer ihre grundstücke nicht
verkaufen und deswegen haben wir uns in
den letzten wochen eben voll und ganz
darauf konzentriert herauszufinden ob
wir diesen hof kaufen wollen oder nicht
weil er so viel mitbringt und so
traumhaft schön ist und wir an dem ort
eben nur noch sehr wenig machen müssen
da wäre eigentlich alles was wir
umsetzen wollen schon da an einem
anderen gold müssten wir wahrscheinlich
komplett von null anfangen jahre sogar
die so einfach da eine entscheidung
treffen weil zb das land also die 25
hektar die zum hof dazu geführt die von
den bisherigen besitzern im moment
bewirtschaftet werden also zu passiert
sind das heißt das grundstück auf dem
das haus steht das gehört einem
natürlich aber da ist kein bisschen grün
mit dabei das heißt man muss erst vom
grundstück runter über eine straße und
dann hat man da jede menge platz alles
zu machen was man machen will
das land gehört eben auch mit einem
selbst sondern irgendwie anders und
damit werden wir dann wieder in so einer
abhängigen situation wie wir es jetzt
sind und eigentlich wollen wir gerade
deswegen etwas eigenes weil wir da keine
lust mehr darauf haben dass und
irgendwann jemanden strich durch die
rechnung macht und sagt chris das war es
jetzt ihr habt zwar hier super viel
arbeit reingesteckt aber wir wollen das
jetzt selber nutzen und dann haben wir
außerdem zwei leute ins haus eingeholt
um das anzuschauen weil das von 1700 ist
das heißt es ist ziemlich alt ziemlich
schief da wurde ziemlich viel dran rum
gebracht sind immer wieder über die
jahrhunderte irgendwas dran gebaut da ja
gibt es so viel zu tun dass wir 300.000
euro da reinstecken müssen damit es so
ist wie wir es gerne hätten und 300.000
euro ich mal der hof selbst ist auch
schon nicht billig
allein da müssten wir eigentlich jetzt
schon sagen da sind wir raus also wie
sollen wir das denn bezahlen
ja also wir morgen einen termin bei der
bank kann bin ich schon sehr gespannt
was der typ dazu sagen will
aber allein die vorstellung dass du so
einen großen kredit aufnehmen und
abbezahlen muss es ist noch nicht ganz
vom tisch weil sie eben nicht damit
gerechnet hatten dass es so teuer werden
würde und weil wir uns da schon so wie
ihr mit beschäftigt haben in den letzten
wochen wir haben da schon übernachtet
haben mit den leuten alles möglich
durchgesprochen hin und her
wir haben mit den ganzen verpächtern
telefoniert und alle wirklich leute
getroffen um das irgendwie möglich zu
machen ja und jetzt kommt das irgendwie
kann ich noch nicht so ganz loslassen
also ich bin sehr gespannt was morgen
mit der bank rauskommt wir werden sehen
[Musik]
aber jetzt aber erstmal an die arbeit im
home-office habe mich selber in der
küche ganz gemütlich wir arbeiten gerade
schon seit seit juli ungefähr haben wir
super hart daran unseren gemüsegarten
staaten kurs zu überarbeiten und haben
den ganzen sommer über bis in den herbst
hinein und jetzt treten wir auch noch
ganz viel gefilmt ganz viele neue videos
für den kurs erstellt und sind da immer
noch dran und ich gerade arbeite gerade
an den gemüse steckbriefen wird das
ebook also ganz viele von euch sind ja
im kurs stimme dabei ihr dürft euch dann
auf jeden fall auch wieder im frühling
auf die neue version freuen auf neue
videos neue tipps und alles wird ein
bisschen schöner und ja es macht total
viel spaß und ich kann es kaum abwarten
dass der kurs endlich fertig wird und
jetzt haben wir gleich teambesprechung
weil ich mache das ja nicht alleine ich
habe auch noch mein team dessen hilfe
den kurs zu erstellen sonst würde ich
das alles überhaupt nicht schaffen und
wir sind alle schon total aufgeregt also
im februar nehmen wir wieder neue
kursteilnehmer auf und bis dahin wird
der kurs in einem neuen licht erstrahlen
und alles noch viel cooler und schöne
und es ist so unglaublich was da
zurückkommt und die bilder zu sehen von
euren gärten ihr könnt so verdammt stolz
auf euch sein
es ist geht vergeht eigentlich kein tag
wo ich nicht denke dass so ein garten
hätte ich auch gerne und ich finde ich
habe schon ganz schön gallen garten aber
ja das ist echt der hammer und das
erfüllt mich mit so viel stolz und das
ist so eine schöne arbeit und wir haben
so ein tolles team und diejenigen von
euch die in den kursen mit dabei sind
kennen ja zum beispiel kathrin und
jackie auch den gruppen und wissen dass
es ganz tolle leute sind und ich bin
super dankbar dafür dass ich so eine
schöne und wichtige arbeit machen darf
[Musik]
dabei mag anfang ist
du fühlst dich sprechen und verwenden
wir sind gerade wieder auf dem weg zum
hof und wollen ein paar offene fragen
klären wahrscheinlich sehr wichtige
fragen und ich erzähle euch nachher mal
nichts gelaufen aber wir sind auf jeden
fall sehr gespannt was sich der heute
noch ergeben wird und ob das vielleicht
einige fragen klärt oder vielleicht
gleich ganz klar doch für den hof
übernehmen oder nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also es ging heute darum wie der ganze
hof weiter laufen wird wenn wir da ein
zweiter bisher mehrere mitarbeiter
arbeiten auf dem hof das ist mehr
soziale landwirtschaft das heißt es ist
ein tool bauernhof da kommen
schulklassen hin und die bisherigen
leute wollen das eben nicht mehr
weitermachen aber es gibt drei
mitarbeiter die super gerne weiter
machen wollen und wir finden dass auch
total toll also es ist ein super schönes
projekt und das ist ganz großartig und
ich würde den hof das hundertprozentig
können dass das so weiter laufen kann
wir haben aber einfach nicht die
kapazitäten einen schulbauernhof zu
führen und wenn gleichzeitig obwohl wir
auf dem hof wohnen und da unser eigenes
projekt daraus machen da trotzdem noch
so viele andere leute auch noch ihr
eigenes ding draus machen obwohl das ja
eigentlich unser privates wohnhaus ist
und unser privater garten und da
trotzdem andauernd irgendwelche leute
durch die vielen dann ist es für uns
nicht so ganz einfach dazu ja zu sagen
auch wenn wir total gut verstehen können
warum die leute das weiter machen wollen
und dass auch eigentlich zu 100 prozent
unterstützen wollen aber halt nicht
unbedingt bei uns zu hause und
vielleicht finden sich ja auch andere
leute die in schulbauernhof weitermachen
wollen die da lust drauf haben ich meine
wir sind nicht so als hätten wir da
keine lust drauf aber wir haben eben
keine kapazitäten weil wir schon voll
und ganz mit dem ausgefüllt sind was wir
machen und ich es auch total schön finde
was wir machen und es ja es soll die
frage wie das dann alles zusammenpassen
kann weil so viel platz ist da nicht
dass man da mit so vielen leuten 1000
projekte verwirklichen könnte gerade in
dem wohnbereich wo zumindest einige der
schulaktivitäten dann einfach bei uns
direkt am haus stattfinden würden es
gibt im moment niemanden der den
schulbauernhof weiterführen würde also
es war auch lange zeit irgendwie eine
überlegung von mir wo ich dachte man
wenn wir den hof kaufen dann machen wir
das ja kaputt für die kinder und das ist
so wichtig dass kinder lernen wo essen
herkommt und wie das tiere fühlen
und eine bezug zur landwirtschaft und
zur natur bin und es ist ein ganz tolles
konzept als die leute da entwickelt
haben
aber es gibt niemanden der den hof
weiterführen will
die leute suchen auch schon länger nach
jemandem das heißt moment zumindest
wegen jeder niemanden das kaputt machen
weil ihm jemand gehört
ich will nicht wieder an waffen gehen
müssen dass ein bewegungsmelder und also
ist es nicht so dass wir uns nicht
vorstellen können auf dem hof auch
gemeinschaftlich mit anderen leuten
zusammen projekte zu machen aber so ein
projekt wo wir absolut gar nicht
involviert werden was so riesig ist und
bei uns zu hause stattfindet es muss
irgendwie nicht sein auch wenn ich es
total toll fände wenn das weiter
passieren könnte aber also wir haben den
mitarbeitern auch allen angeboten dass
sie bei uns bei wurzelwerk arbeiten
können ja vielleicht ist das auch eine
tolle lösung dass die ihren job nicht
verlieren und trotzdem super dahinter
weitermachen können es ist so komplex
alles ich habe ja auch bisher nur ein
bruchteil erzählt von dem was uns gerade
so umtreibt weil ich euch jetzt nicht
überfrachten will mit diesem ganzen
problemen und in so ist und so weiter
morgen haben wir den termin mit der bank
und danach wissen wir auf jeden fall
schon ob das mit der finanzierung
klappen kann oder nicht
und vielleicht ist es dann auch einfach
klar dass wir weiter schauen müssen was
auf jeden fall klar ist dass wir eine
wohnung gefunden haben zum glück das war
ja auch ziemlich schwierig was zu finden
wir hatten teilweise 24 mitbewerber auf
eine frau die wohnung schön wie ist zwar
sehr unpraktisch geschnitten und liegt
mitten in der stadt hat keinen garten
wenn man das fenster aufmacht dass man
eigentlich direkt an der hauptstraße
aber es ist ja nur eine übergangslösung
und wenn wir da ein zwei jahre
verbringen müssen bis wir einen anderen
hof gefunden haben dann ist es so aber
hoffentlich auch wenn wir diesen hof
jetzt nicht nehmen
finden wir irgendwas anderes probieren
sagen können ja das passt zu 100 prozent
da können wir voll und ganz
dahinterstehen dass er so schön
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind von der bank zurück es war
richtig nett da ich dachte nicht der
banker so sympathisch sind
aber wir haben im moment nicht genug
eigenkapital um so einen hohen kredit
bekommen zu können was bedeuten könnte
dass sich das ganze projekt einfach aus
schieben würde wenn es keine anderen
interessenten gibt und sich die leute
darauf einlassen oder das ist das jetzt
wahr
ich denke das wird sich in den nächsten
tagen herausstellen ja aber schon ein
kleiner dämpfer
nur eigentlich war es uns halt auch klar
dass es einfach extrem teuer geworden
ist dadurch dass die renovierungskosten
so extrem hoch sind
[Musik]
übrigens da kam ja immer wieder mal
kommentare in die richtung und ich hab
hoffe dass ihr mein video nicht
missversteht ich möchte nicht dass ihr
mir geld schickt es gab so viele
kommentare von leuten die uns
unterstützen wollen
und das finde ich total lieb von euch
aber ich würde das niemals annehmen
können und es ist ja nicht so dass es
uns finanziell irgendwie schlecht gehen
würde der hof ist nur einfach verdammt
teuer sehen müsst euch keine sorgen
machen und bitte schreib mir das nicht
ich finde es super süß von euch und so
blieb aber wie gesagt ich könnte das
echt nicht annehmen wenn ihr uns
unterstützen wollt dann kaufte im
februar den garten kuhls wetter kriegt
ihr was richtig cooles zurück und dann
habe ich auch richtig gutes gefühl dabei
war das was wo ich zu hunderttausend
prozent dahinter stehe und genau weiß
dass es euch auch richtig weiterhelfen
würde wenn ihr uns unterstützt und das
macht mich schon denn diese die videos
schaut und indem ihr auf unsere links
klickt die uns manchmal in der video
beschreibungen sind wenn wir irgendwas
verlinken dann verdienen wieder manchmal
ein bisschen geld daran mit also das
hilft uns schon ungemein und dann bitte
so dass wir euch dafür auch etwas
zurückgeben können auch wenn es total
dieses von euch also nicht falsch
verstehen aber ich möchte auf jeden fall
nicht das jetzt irgendwer hier denkt ich
würde das video machen damit ich mitleid
erwecken das sollte mir geld schicken
sollen
ja was den hof angeht werden inhalt
abend mit denen sie sitzen reden wir
werden ja darüber sprechen wie das mit
der gemeinsamen nutzung aussehen könnte
wie es mit der finanzierung aussehen
könnte aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt
nicht das gefühl als wenn wir es machen
allein schon weil wir den schulbauernhof
dadurch kaputt machen würden und weil
ich eigentlich findet sollte noch viel
mehr schuhe bauernhöfe geben und ich
nicht schuld daran sein möchte das ist
eigentlich mehr gibt
und der mann gesprochen
dankeschön ja ja auch allesamt er sehe
nicht so dass wir wissen wie wir hätten
nur einfach ein schlechtes gefühl dass
kaputt zu machen also ihr habt das
wahrscheinlich herausgehört wir haben
gestern abend in hof abgesagt weil es
einfach letztendlich zu teuer ist weil
wir keine lust haben selbst wenn wir es
uns irgendwann leisten können so einen
hohen kredit abzahlen zu müssen also es
wirklich für die gegend in der wir
wohnen werde hof einfach übertrieben
teuer zu recht also natürlich ist das
auch wert aber mit den
renovierungskosten ist es einfach zu
viel
und dann kommt dazu dass wir das gefühl
haben dass wir einfach nicht die leute
sind die diesen hof übernehmen sollten
auch wenn das total schade ist weil wir
mit ihm und uns selber total wünschen
würden und der super toll ist wirklich
richtig schön aber wenn es irgendwie die
möglichkeit gibt dass dieser
schulbauernhof der weiter läuft und dass
kinder da bauernhof erleben können dann
wäre das einfach toll weil da ist die
ganze infrastruktur schon da und wenn
wir dahin ziehen würden dann wäre das in
dem maße zumindest nicht mehr weiter
möglich allein was ich an meinem sohn
sehe wie er aufgeht darin dass er das
alles mitbekommt wo es herkommt dass er
genau jedes einzelne tier kennt was
unsere eier legt dass unsere milch gibt
und absolut zu schätzen weiß dass das
wichtig die arbeit war bis des lebens
mit auf den tisch war das ist so viel
wert und ich fände es toll wenn du es da
weiter laufen könnte und ich zurück den
leuten die das noch in die daumen dass
sie das hinbekommen dass sie vielleicht
irgendwann anders finden der den hof
leiten möchte und wir werden dafür
einfach nicht die richtigen leute weil
wir da hat mir einfach keine zeit
und deswegen am berliner hof abgesagt
was total schade ist weil wir und dann
wirklich schon super viel mit
beschäftigt hatten
aber am anfang war eben noch gar nicht
klar dass die leute das weitermachen
wollen die da bisher arbeiten also die
drei mitarbeiter und da sah das ganze
autos ob der hof einfach verkauft würde
als ob das eh nicht zur debatte steht
dass der weitergeführt würde
und jetzt wo das vielleicht irgendwie
möglich ist werden wir dem nicht im weg
stehen wollen und außerdem passt es ja
auch an anderen enden nicht richtig zu
dem was sie machen wollen
also werden wir weiter suchen wir werden
jetzt erstmal diesen umzug hinter uns
bringen mich wundern ihr werdet noch
einige videos hier aus dieser küche
sehen weil wir noch bis ungefähr mitte
januar hier wohnen und weil ich vor dem
umzug auch ein paar videos vor filmen
werde damit wir damit weiter jeden
samstag ein video und dann geht auch
wenn wir vielleicht mit dem umzug
beschäftigt sind
dann sag ich euch wo wir dann holen die
neue wohnung ist aufstehen also ich
freue mich da auch schon drauf dazu
wurden auch wenn es in der lage ja und
ohne garten und soweit es eben nicht
perfekt aber wir können ja den garten
hier weiter nutzen das habe ich ja schon
erzählt also alles gut ich würde weiter
garten videos geben und wir halten
unseren garten haben und dann
hoffentlich bald irgendwo an einem ort
ankommen wo wir dann alles hin umziehen
können aber seitlich enttäuscht wenn das
jetzt erst mal keine updates gibt zuruf
suche weil wir jetzt wie gesagt erst mal
umziehen dann steht im februar
der garten kurs an da habe ich so viel
zu tun dass ich wahrscheinlich überhaupt
nichts anderes schaffen werde
und dann können wir im laufe des
frühlings weiter auf hof suche gehen und
dann hoffentlich irgendwann irgendwas
finden und ich werde euch natürlich
berichten wenn sich da wieder was tut
aber jetzt sind wir auch erst mal ganz
froh dass wir uns mit anderen sachen
beschäftigen können weil es eben zu
anstrengend ist und so wichtige
entscheidungen zu treffen sind und wir
jetzt gerade ganz viele andere projekte
haben die die erste priorität haben und
dann geht es weiter